dans le milieu de la télé les gens sont
souvent vos amis quand vous êtes en
place mais le jour où vous êtes en
difficulté la plupart du temps les
baisses se retourne c'est l'amère
expérience qu'a vécu le journaliste
stéphane pauwels lors qu'en 2018 il est
accusé de participation présumée à un
cambriolage au domicile de l'ex
compagnon de sa femme
à partir de là c'est la descente aux
enfers tout ses employeurs le laisse
tomber mes aventures qui n'est pas le
seul à avoir vécu
c'est le cas également de philippe
risoli animateur star de tf1 dans les
années 90 2000 pour la carrière s'est
arrêtée du jour au lendemain sans
explication on est les rois du monde
pendant un certain temps et tout d'un
coup sûr un coup de téléphone tout peut
s'arrêter vous dégage des difficultés
qui ont aussi été celle de benjamin
castaldi
après avoir été la superstar de la
chaîne m6 puis de tf1 au fil des années
cette collaboration avec la première
chaîne tourne mal et les difficultés
commencent à cette période seuls deux
animateurs lui ont tendu la main fait
dans ce métier je dois deux personnes où
je dois drucker qui m'a fait commencer
je dois hanouna qui m'a récupéré alors
le monde des médias est il un milieu de
faux culs stéphane pauwels était avec
nous pour nous parler de son histoire
et bien sûr on va parler des histoires
de chacun ici oui si on paie les pots
car cela peut rapidement
isabelle merci stéphane merci d'être là
c'est stéphane qui a traversé une set ça
a été un enfer que tu as traversé alors
tout le monde te lâcher du jour au
lendemain c'est fait tu étais sûr qu
elle chez toi tu étais tu étais une
énorme star je te connais bien on a fait
des choses ensemble bien sûr en belgique
ouais ouais c'est ça fonctionnait pas
mal et notamment pour résumer trois
jours avant l'arrestation je vais faire
les matches des bleus sur m6 avec alain
boghossian et les sapins et donc ça
s'est arrêté du jour au lendemain pour
une histoire de ouf que j'avais rien à
voir ça m'a mis du temps c'était quoi
l'histoire
en fait j'ai on est venu me chercher
j'étais en interview à rtl qu'on soit
bien contexte avec eric emmanuel schmitt
c'est les flics viennent me chercher et
on m'accuse pas ce qu'on me dit que j'ai
fait un volet de violence un home avaaz
ion je ne sais pas de quoi ils parlent
je dors la nuit en prison et je me rends
compte que j'avais une quand une
campagne à l'époque de sept mois qui
s'étaient vengés d'alex et avec mon
téléphone elle a envoyé l'adresse de
l'ex pour aller faire casser la gueule
mais moi je tombe dans un truc on prend
un avocat on sait pas en fait quand on
n'est pas dans ce truc là on vous avait
été lavé de tout soupçon depuis mais
n'entraînera n'ont jamais été lavé de
tout soupçon j'ai pris alors forcément
quand même savoir qui avait plein de
reculs passion qui se sont rajoutés des
as cotation sécurité mise par les médias
qu'ils ont rajouté rajouter et le
procureur général avait demandé cinq ans
et demi de prison ferme
qu'on s'entende bien qu'il ya deux sms
et un oeil au beurre noir donc moi je
suis dit c'est quoi ce truc je m'en sors
30 mois de prison avec sursis ce qui est
énorme pour rien pourquoi j'ai pas
l'avenir mais pourquoi vous avez
peut-être en appel et parce que pendant
deux ans et demi en maille ma tronche
tous les jours 122 première de
couverture avec une bande qui s'appelait
à kimi qui avait fait 28 oh ma vision et
détient de ces mecs là qui faisait un
truc boom ont collé ma photo moi je suis
père de famille un moment j'ai dit si je
vais en appel ils vont quand même encore
me charger parce que chalon public et
qu'il fallait parce que c'est ça aussi
le gros problème c'est que quand et je
pense que d'autres ont vécu ça c'est que
quand on est un homme public avec un
moment la presse y va de bon coeur et
vous le verrez dans le bouquin ils ont
inventé même de la téléphonie qui
n'existe pas pour la mercedes qui suit
la gueule des trucs qui n'a jamais
existé dans le dossier il ya un moment
il ya une espèce d'enflammade qui se
fait que ya un moment on doit vous punir
un moment donné on doit vous punir et
vous êtes impuissant vous êtes enfermé
chez vous votre téléphone sonne plus et
juste pour vous dire parce que j'ai
insisté et merci d'être chez vous les
français m'ont tendu la main en belgique
ça c'est fermé la juge m'interdit
d'aller 1 en france alors que je vivais
entre la belgique et boulogne
billancourt interdit d'aller en france
dont le plus de travail
toutes les télés se sont jamais trois
prime time tous amis arrêter du jour au
lendemain il ya deux mecs qui m'ont
tendu la main je le dis c'est christian
ollivier le rédacteur en chef des sports
j'adore j'oublierai que jamais ça j'en
extrais énorme et j'en ai des frissons
vous en parler et yves bigot le patron
tv5 monde est ok et ça moi ça ça vaut
plus que tout parce que ces mecs parce
que la présomption d'innocence et à un
moment elle doit exister quoi y'en a
marre qu'on charge et 100 et 100
derrière regrouper
avait vu le titre de mon livre c'est le
titre que le journal ratp ils ont ouvert
le journal le lendemain de mon
arrestation de la lumière à l'infamie
mon père est instituteur savez ce que
c'est le moins famille c'est horrible et
moi j'y vois là j'étais très bien tout
perdu j'ai tout perdu et c'est à dire
que j'avais trois prime time je
présentais la champion s league
j'avais dit que je travaille à la chaîne
l'équipe je suis régulièrement je fais
ça s'est arrêté comme ça fait deux ans
et demi j'ai maintenant des petites
pistes parfois j'ai la chance de côtoyer
gillet les copains sur rtl mais je fais
partie d'un collectif
à tv5 je vais gagner ma vie je commande
des matches mais j'avais les orages de
la vie j'avais staff fait déjà effectué
le monde des médias
c'est un monde on va pas se tourner ça
monte de jaloux bah c'est ça votre mot
focus est ce que vous êtes bien que très
clairement il est jaloux c'est plutôt un
monde de jaloux c'est d'accord ne
supporte pas dans cette société de
succès des autres je sais que vous vous
êtes souvent défendu d'ailleurs merci
sylvain tessier et je vous ai défendu
j'ai défendu aussi benjamin castaldi
il ya un moment mais il fait des
approximations et un mélange tout dire
qu'il ya du talent il ya des gens qui
moi et je voudrais terminer avec ça
c'est quand on est magistrat mais tu es
quelqu'un de connu vous êtes quelqu'un
de connu
c'est normal vous avez profité de cette
méditation de cette médiatisation pour
arriver à quelque chose mais non on a
travaillé pour ça et donc cette bêtise à
sion elle existe est forcément ben on va
pas cracher dessus on a tous de lego moi
le premier mais y'a un moment parce que
vous êtes quelqu'un une personnalité
publique
on vous assomme quoi et moi j'étais le
plus un sommet vous savez il ya qu'une
vérité dans ce métier si les
téléspectateurs c'est c'est les gens qui
regardent les gens qui me regardent et
les genôts si vous regardez ça ça c'est
la richesse mais ces petits gratte
papier qui sont souvent frustrés et qui
rêve d'une chose c'est d'aller en
télévision c'est le problème c est le
cancer de notre métier c'est ces gens
frustrés qu'ils le font pas et qui
rêveraient de l'être c'est ça j'aimerais
même les vrais journalistes
madame tous ces gens ici on n'est pas
comme ça mais ça fait 20 ans qu'elle
fait des chroniques ou peu plus de types
de 200 400 mais il ya un moment il ya un
travail moi c'est ça qui m'énerve dans
ce dossier c'est une source souvent vous
êtes chargé matraque gens qui n'ont pas
de compétences et qu'ils ont envie de se
faire plaisir et ça me gonfle et
chandioux